"Many years ago, the great British explorer George Mallory,
who was to die on Mount Everest,
was asked, "why did he want to climb it?"
He said "because it is there".
Well space is there, and we're going to climb it.
And the moon and the planets are there,
and new hopes for knowledge and peace are there.
And therefore, as we set sail, we ask God's blessing on the most hazardous and dangerous and
greatest adventure on which man has ever embarked."
- President John F. Kennedy
"Look at the stars,
the great kings of the past look down on us from those stars."
"Really?"
"Yes."
"So whenever you feel alone
just remember,
those kings will always be there to guide you."
- The Lion King (1994)
"There is a tingling in the spine, a catch in the voice,
a faint sensation, as if a distant memory,
of falling, from a great height.
We know you're approaching the grandest of mysteries."
- Carl Sagan (Cosmos, 1980)
"Old books?"
"Stories written before space travel,
but,
about, space travel."
"How could there have been stories about space travel, before - - ?"
"The writers," Pris said.
"They made it up."
- Philip K. Dick (Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep? 1968)
"What is it you want, Mary?"
"What do you want, y-you want the moon?"
"Just say the word and I'll throw a lasso around it and pull it down."
"Hey that's a pretty good idea."
"I'll give you the moon, Mary."
"I'll take it."
- It's a Wonderful Life (1946)
That's one small step for man,